He says
that we will certainly try you
with something
of fear
and hunger
and loss of life
and
loss of wealth and life human life
and investment.
So, give glad tidings to those who have
patience.
The ones who, when calamity befalls
them, they say
to Allah we belong and to him we shall
return.
Those are the ones
who Allah will shower with his blessings
and mercy.
And those are the ones who are truly
guided. You see, from an Islamic
perspective death is where life begins.
And from this perspective, you could say
that we're an impossible enemy
because the worst thing you can do to a
Muslim is kill them.
But for us
death is the beginning.
So, when it comes to
those white supremacists who have
taken the lives
of those 49, 50 people in Christchurch
thinking
that they are ridding the world of the
invading enemy, to put it in
Tarrant, the the killer's, the
terrorists' words
of the invading enemy, what he's
actually doing
is he's hardening the efforts
and he's strengthening the spirit of
Muslims all around the world.
And here's what you need to understand.
That this narrative, which has been
promulgated by right-wing extremists,
who have been, frankly
the knowledge producers
for the Islamophobic
atmosphere
through which and by which such
terroristic minds can develop.
Those people who've had this discourse
of the peculiar Muslim other abject
other
that is
distinctively known by his violence
and uniquely understood by his terrorism
that discourse has been destabilized.
And it's not just on this occasion.
We have to be clear. There was the
Chapel Hill shooting. There was Breivik
killing 77 innocents. And now you have
this man
Br- Brenton Tarrant or whatever his name
is, killing 50 individuals, many of
which are children. And he wanted the
world to know about it and he filmed it
on social media and he called himself a
terrorist in his manifesto. There's no
running away from it.
He was inspired
yes
by his own ideological justification.
And there is a continuity here between
right-wing rhetoric
especially ultra-right and alternative
right-wing rhetoric and his own
understanding of the world, especially
in relation to immigration.
Which is why we find a lot of people
from the right now coming out and
condemning the attack
in reminiscent terms because this of
course reminds us of how Muslims Muslim
leaders usually come and you know,
condemn attacks.
And for once in their life, they have
been able to introduce nuance to the
discussion.
I I watched Steven Crowder. I watched
um
Ben Shapiro.
I watched even Katie Hopkins.
And their responses
seem to indicate that look, there's
entanglement of different contributing
factors
all of which shaped this individual, one
of which was ideology, a lot of them
admit.
But it wasn't the only thing. The Daily
Mail goes much further than that,
painting a picture of this man and
calling him the angelic boy, that his
father had cancer and so on.
As if look, we have to look at this
thing
from different angles. But that nuance
that they now introduced to the
terroristic discussion was never
introduced
from their own knowledge producers and
contributors
when Muslim terrorists commit acts.
It has to be reduced to a low lowest
common multiple and it many times, if
not always, has to be Islam itself.
So, why is it the case that it's
inconceivable for the right-wing mind
that there's a potentiality within their
own ideological systems for people to
churn out a net
terrorism which emerges on our streets
and our mosques?
Why is it inconceivable for you to
realize that terrorism can be committed
by secular whites? It's that thesis that
you've tried to superimpose upon the
sociological reality which has now
become untenable.
It's that discourse that you have tried
to iterate and reiterate
into public spheres and through your
platforms which has been totally
destabilized now.
There's no more media
covering it up. The man himself wanted
to be known.
And now they're trying to censor his
name
and censor his material
with the pretense, by the way, this is a
pretense, of
yes, we don't want to give him
notoriety.
No, that's a pretense. The reason why
you want to censor his name and you want
to censor his actions is because you
don't want us to reference him. That you
know this is an entry point for
academics. You know this is an entry
point for people to criticize and
reference this as a white supremacist
which was
inspired by right-wing terrorist, as a
terrorist.
And now the body of work of right-wing
terrorist is starting to become
self-evident, so much so that it's
become impossible
for politicians and other elites
to ignore it.
And at this point it's important for us
to say, we do actually we actually do
appreciate all the support.
With all the anger that we have
that there has been community
togetherness
and support from all different aspects
all different parts of society. And we
thank non-Muslim society communities for
showing us your support.
We also would like to show you our
gratitude for that.
This is exactly what we need to do.
We need to realize that they there are
people of different dispositions,
ideological, religious or otherwise,
that are capable of these monstrous
terroristic acts.
And that the mo- the main motivating
factor
for those individuals is usually the
same. It's an emotive one rather than an
intellectual one
where they
they see themselves living in a state of
perpetual war and conflict and they want
to enact their school of duty style
role where they themselves are becoming
the
main protagonist
and getting rid of the
enemies.
And of course, one thing runs almost
consistently throughout all of these
themes
which is that there is an element of
ideological justification, whether it be
from
those terrorists from our side
or those from from the right-wing side.
And that justification annuls or
otherwise nullifies
the
the principle of non-combatant immunity.
It nullifies the principle of
non-combatant immunity, but that is not
particular to Islam.
And it's not particular to Muslims. So,
the narrative is now being forcibly
changed by virtue of the fact that we
live in a hyper-globalized world and
events cannot be
disguised or otherwise camouflaged
anymore.
Social media is overtaking the media.
This man himself
wanted people to know he was a
terrorist. No matter what the media
says, this information is freely
available to us and it can never be
reversed.
So, the right-wing needs to come to
terms with itself
its immigration rhetoric and kicking
these people out and re-whitening the
discourse. That all needs to be
reassessed because it it provides
fertile grounds
for the kind of touristic actions
that we see or will have seen
in Christchurch.
I want to end this this
video by saying something very important
which is the following.
It's high time
that we have discussions and debates
that the Muslim traditionalist Muslim
community, especially those who adhere
to classical jurisprudential
understanding of Islam
and right-wing advocates
that we have discussions and debates on
points of tension in controlled settings
such that
misconceptions can be corrected. Why is
it the case that I always find myself
telling people that look, Islam doesn't
tell people to go and kill innocents.
That in chapter 60 verse 8, chapter 5
verse 32, and the prophet you know,
killing one person is like killing the
whole of humanity. The prophet told us
not to kill women and children and so
on. Why do I always have to repeat
myself and then be told that I'm lying?
That actually this is not what you
believe or that it is not what you ought
to believe if you're a classical
traditionalist Muslim. Don't tell me
what I should believe. I know my
scriptures more than the right-wing
English-speaking and no other language
person who's telling me what I should
read
I should believe. Don't tell me what I
should believe. I know what we should
believe. So let's have these
discussions. We need to fix these
misconceptions. Someone like Ben
Shapiro.
Someone like Milo.
Someone like
Jordan Peterson. This is an open
invitation. I'm not going to call it an
open challenge. This is an open
invitation
for dialogue
and discussion
where we have equal time to talk and ask
questions from each other.
And
where we can probe each other. I think
this is necessary and I think it will
solve a lot of societal problems.
But in regards to what we should do for
the people of Christchurch
we should make dua for them. As the
Muslims, we have to make supplication
for them.
And realize
that the Prophet Muhammad I'm going to
end with this. The Prophet Muhammad said
something beautiful. And this is in
Hadith of Tirmidhi.
He says, "Man qutila duna malihi fahuwa
shaheed." Whoever is killed protecting
their wealth, he's a shaheed. "Man
qutila duna damihi fahuwa shaheed."
Whoever is killed protecting their blood
I e. themselves, then he's a shaheed.
"Duna ahlihi fahuwa shaheed." Protecting
their families, fahuwa shaheed. He's a
martyr. He's a martyr. He's a martyr.
So we believe that these individuals are
martyrs. There's no doubt about that.
And even we should ask Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to give them the high stations
of Jannah and to make us with them. And
I'll leave it that. Salaam alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.